>> Laura: YOU JUST KNEW THE
MEDIA WOULD HAVE A TOUGH TIME
ACKNOWLEDGING ANOTHER TRUMP
TRIUMPH.
THEY FOUND A WAY TO CRITICIZE
THE PRESIDENT AS HE GREETED
THREE AMERICAN HOSTAGES RELEASED
FROM NORTH KOREA.
>> YOU HAVE THREE PRISONERS OF
THE NORTH KOREAN SLAVE STATE,
IT'S ABOUT DONALD TRUMP, ABOUT
THE RATINGS.
>> HOW LONG WILL IT BE BEFORE
THESE IMAGES ARE TURNED AROUND.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A FORMER
REALITY PRODUCER.
THIS WAS A STAGED PRODUCTION
MEANT FOR TELEVISION, MEANT FOR
THE CAMERAS.
>> Laura: MAYBE SHE'S HAVING
AMNESIA.
JUST FOUR YEARS AGO PRESIDENT
OBAMA STAGED A PHOTO OP
ANNOUNCING THE ARMY.
OBAMA TRADED FIVE TERRORISTS WHO
PLED GUILTY TO DESERTION.
RIGHT FROM THE BEGINNING, OBAMA,
WHEN HE WAS NOMINATED, HE WENT
TO THAT INVESCO FIELD SPEECH IN
DENVER.
THEY BROUGHT IN THE ROMAN
COLUMNS.
HE WAS GOOD AT STAGE PRODUCTION.
HERE WE HAVE TRUMP AT 3:00 IN
THE MORNING GOING TO GREET THE
HOSTAGES AND EVERYBODY IS HAVING
A MELTDOWN.
>> THE PRESIDENT WENT OUT TO
GIVE THEM A HERO'S WELCOME.
SOME HAVE TO MINIMIZE IT.
IT BECOMES ANOTHER ANTI-TRUMP
STORY.
HE DIDN'T SHOW ENOUGH EMPATHY,
HE DIDN'T BITE HIS LOWER LIP AND
FEEL THEIR PAIN.
SAME THING WHEN HE WENT TO VISIT
THE HURRICANE VICTIMS.
>> Laura: LESLIE, HERE'S A
YAHOO! HEADLINE.
TRUMP CHEAPENS NORTH KOREA
HOSTAGE RETURN.
HE MADE AN OFF-HAND COMMENT
ABOUT WE'LL GET RATINGS AT 3 IN
THE MORNING.
THAT'S TRUMP.
HE'S NOT MAKING IT ABOUT HIMSELF
GETTING RATINGS.
THIS COMPARED TO BILL CLINTON IN
2009, HERE'S HEADLINES, RELEASE
OF JOURNALISTS, BOTH CLINTONS
HAD KEY ROLES.
BILL CLINTON AND JOURNALISTS,
EMOTIONAL RETURN TO THE U.S.,
AUGUST 5, 2009 WHEN HE GOT
PRISONERS RELEASED FROM NORTH
KOREA.
THE DOUBLE STANDARD, WHETHER YOU
ARE A REPUBLICAN OR DIPLOMAT,
HAVE SOME FAIRNESS.
>> I HAVE TO SAY, I AM A
DEMOCRAT WHO LOVES TO ATTACK THE
PRESIDENT EVERY CHANCE I GET.
BUT THIS ONE SHOULD BE ABOUT
THESE THREE MEN RELEASED, IT
SHOULD NOT BE ABOUT POLITICS.
I DIDN'T THINK AND I KNOW
LEFTIES GET MAD AT ME, I DIDN'T
THINK IT WAS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT BOTHERED ME WHEN HE GAVE
CREDIT TO KIM JONG UN.
THESE MEN WERE IMPRISONED, THEY
WERE IN THE DARK, THEY WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO GO OUTSIDE, NOT GIVEN
PROPER FOOD OR WATER OR MEDICAL
ATTENTION.
THAT WAS THE THING THAT BOTHERED
ME THE MOMENT AND THE COMMENTS
ABOUT THE RATINGS.
IT IS TRUMP.
WE HOPE DAY AFTER DAY, HE WILL
BECOME MORE PRESIDENTIAL AND
FORGET THE SIZE OF CLOUD.
>> THERE IS A LITTLE
INCONSISTENCY.
WHEN HE WAS ATTACKING LITTLE
ROCKET MAN, HE WAS DENOUNCED AS
CRAZY.
YES, HE'S SAYING THINGS ABOUT
HIM BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO MEET
HIM AND TRY TO NEGOTIATE AND TRY
TO NEGOTIATE A NUCLEAR
DISARMAMENT.
A LOT OF THINGS HE DOES IS
CONTROVERSIAL.
BRINGING HOME AMERICAN HOSTAGES,
THAT'S NOT CONTROVERSIAL.
>> Laura: NOBODY THINKS THE
PRESIDENT BELIEVES KIM JONG UN
IS A NICE GUY.
HE SAYS CHUCK SCHUMER AND I ARE
PAULS.
PALS.
THIS IS PART OF THE ART OF THE
DEAL.
HE KNOWS WHEN HE GOES TO
SINGAPORE ON JUNE 12, THIS IS A
DICEY DEAL, NO ONE TRUSTS THEM,
WE HAVE HAD A LONG HISTORY OF
THEM GOING BACK ON THEIR
AGREEMENTS.
HE GOES IN WITH EYES WIDE OPEN.
I THINK IT'S VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL THE AMERICANS
WHO ARE WATCHING THE SHOW
TONIGHT TO REMEMBER HOW THE
PRESS TREAT DEMOCRATS WHEN THEY
HAVE SOME GOOD NEWS FOR THE
COUNTRY VERSUS HOW THEY TREAT
THIS PRESIDENT, HE'S HAD
MULTIPLE SUCCESSES AND THE
COVERAGE IS NOT ANYWHERE NEAR
BALANCED.
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO, DO YOU
THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
TUNING OUT A LOT OF THIS GIVEN
THAT THE NUMBERS ARE GOING UP
FOR TRUMP?
>> WHAT.
>> Laura: THE BIAS, TREATING THE
PRESS LIKE THEY ARE IRRELEVANT.
>> THEY HAVE CONCLUDED THIS